RACE AND TO CAMPAIGN SAYS THAT
TWO ARE EXACTLY THE SAME, KIND
OF FALLS INTO THAT CATEGORY.
LET'S BRING IN THE PANEL,
THANKS, HILLARY.
SENIOR POLITICAL CORRESPONDENT,
YOU'RE WITH MOLLIE HEMINGWAY,
SENIOR CHIEF FOR THE
FEDERALISTS, I DON'T THINK THAT
I HAVE SEEN AN ENDORSEMENT TO
THAT JUST SAYS ERIC.
>> YOU CAN HEAR A LOT OF
REPUBLICANS BREATHING A SIGH OF
RELIEF IN MISSOURI, BECAUSE
THERE WAS A FEAR THAT TRUMP
WOULD ENDORSE ERIC BRIGHTENS,
ACCUSED BY HIS EX-WIFE OF ABUSE
AND THAT WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN A
GOOD LOOK FOR THE PARTY AND
GIVEN A CHANCE FOR THE FORMER
GOVERNOR TO WIN, NOW IT LOOKS
LIKE THE ATTORNEY GENERAL
ERIC SCHMIDT IS THE CLEAR
FAVORITES, AND DONALD TRUMP
DECIDED TO NOT GET INVOLVED IN
THAT RACE.
>> Bret: IF EITHER ERIC WINS
IT DOES THE FORMER PRESIDENT GET
THE W?
>> THIS PRIMARY WAS SUCH A MESS
AND HAD SO MANY PERSONAL ISSUES
IN PLAY I THINK THAT HE PROBABLY
PLAYED IT ABOUT RIGHT BY
ESSENTIALLY STAYING OUT OF IT BY
JUST WAITING TILL THE LAST
MINUTE TO GIVE HIS BLESSING TO
BOTH CANDIDATES, INTERESTING TO
SEE HOW HIS ENDORSEMENT IN
ARIZONA WAS LIKE MASTERING AND
OTHER KEY RACES WILL PLAY OUT TO
SEE THE EFFECT OF THE SUPPORT.
>> Bret: I NEED TO CHECK IF
VICKI HUCK'S LAWYERS HAVE MIDDLE
NAME IS ERIC, THAT'S THE REAL
QUESTION, A LONG DAY FOR
PRIMARIES AROUND THE COUNTRY.
>> IT WILL CERTAINLY TELL US A
LOT MORE ABOUT PRESIDENT TRUMP'S
POLE, THERE IS A THIRD ERIC
HENRY GOMEZ IN OHIO FOUND ERIC
McELROY ON THE BALLOT, SO WE
ARE NOT SURE HE IS OUT OF IT,
BUT WHAT JOSH SAID IS TRUE,
RADIOACTIVE, AND PERSUASIVELY
ACCUSED OF DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
AGAINST HIS WIFE AND CHILD,
PLUMMETING IN THE POLLS AND THE
FORMER PRESIDENT PLAYS AT DOWN
THE MIDDLE.
HE IS STRONG AHEAD, AND THE
GOVERNOR'S RACE HAS GONE AWAY
FOR NOT KEVIN WINKY WHO I
THOUGHT HE WAS GOING TO GO FOR
WHICH IS OFTEN A CURVEBALL FOR
PEOPLE, BUT I THINK AT THE END
OF THE DAY WILL TURN OUT TO BE
SOMETHING THAT PEOPLE